first I just had a refresher of the
three kinds of views of free well
dualism found physically
non-physiological libertarian frugal
which is basically that the mind is
independent of the brain this is what
Dan is saying it was dispelled a long
time ago by everybody compatibilism that
free will is compatible with the idea of
determinism or laws of physics I think
that's what most of the people in this
room are I mean we all agree that the
laws of physics reign supreme so the
question is given that and the form of
determinism that that entails um do we
still have free will and then there's
ank Dan as an advocate of compatible as
soon as we also nobody in this room but
a lot of people in this society are
advocates of non-physical libertarian
free well and finally in compatibilism
which is my own view that free will is
not compatible with the idea of
determinism one of the laws of physics
of course this depends on what your
definition of free will is when you
adjudicate between the last two and I
would maintain that compatible lists
have redefined free well from its
traditional and indigenous meaning in
society in a way to either I mean I
think Dan's motivation might be the one
to keep people from acting like beasts
as far as I can see there are
conflicting results between different
scientific studies about whether people
are innately duelists or not the people
I've talked to when you tell them that
their decisions have already been made
for the before they make them are
shocked I mean and when you question
them more deeply you realize that people
seem to indeed think that they are
agents and they can really make
decisions but that's just my personal
experience
so anyway I'm an incompatible list I
think that I retain the definition this
is my definition of free will you have
to have a definition of free will in
order to be able to see whether they're
compatible stirring compatibilist
my definition used to be at which was
similar what Shawn was talking about if
you put yourself in the same situation
in the same universe with every molecule
in the same place free will would mean
that you have the opportunity that if
you come to a decision point you could
make more than one decision okay but
then I realize that quantum
indeterminacy if it acts on the general
level could make you make a different
decision and under the circumstances
that it could even make you make a
conscious different decision if that's
somehow that angle that quantum
indeterminacy somehow plays out in your
consciousness so I've taken this
definition from Anthony cash where in
his PNAS paper the belief that there is
something more than the consequences of
your genes and your environment sheer
behavior and and taking into account the
possible stochastic effects sorry well
and all it is is it's the physicalist or
materialist definition of okay well I
mean you could get past this huh these
are this is a man to be provocative okay
and I also have to say that I freely
admit that I'm not a philosopher I've
been accused of philosophical naivete
and there's some truth in this and also
what I say about in compatibilism here
is not necessarily am it the
incomparable sorry at the compatible
lists in this room it just sort of might
take them the whole viewpoint so first
of all I mean let me talk about what I
think we all in this room agree on
I think Dan's talked reinforced this
that there is no dualism there's no
ghost of the machine the mind is the
equivalent to the brain second of all we
don't have point in free will in the
sense that I say we can only make one
decision at one time I really think
that's true
others argue about whether quantum
indeterminacy can affect our behavior I
as far as I can see it doesn't at least
from you know making decisions so we
have to define free well differently to
get comparable ism we can make no
decisions other than the ones we do at a
given moment unless klimer indeterminacy
affects the decision process if it
doesn't then I think we were all agree
if we choose between vanilla or
chocolate ice cream unity point that
decision has already been made for us
before it reaches our consciousness
for certain things a little bit you
could deal with this clump deployment
determinacy issue just by saying that
there is an objective prediction about
what you will do next
given by the actors you mentioned it
might be determined 100% or maybe
probabilistic but its objective based on
your atoms yeah and that's what catch my
eye you said we will agree I don't agree
with your last statement about chocolate
of vanilla ice cream I don't think that
even on a completely non dualistic point
of view that we are that are that the
decision is made that we will have
chocolate or vanilla
before we consciously decide that okay
well there's some neuro scientific
experiments I mean something like I
guess your theories about that you can
predict which button you're going to
press with a certain degree of accuracy
before you consciously decide which well
we can discuss those together okay but
they they're very in a very limited
context them yeah okay well anyway given
the laws of physics I claim that this is
almost an a priori truth and finally
we're probably smart genes that are
environmentally okay
my problem with comparable ISM is best
expressed with my Sam Harris
I mean in some sense I agree with Dan
that we have a manifest image of
freewill but I think it's it's crucial
to recognize the reality for other
reasons I mean Dan wants to keep the
manifest image because he thinks society
will fall apart if we don't accept that
I think that there are pernicious
consequences of of not recognizing
determinism in terms of our decisions
and well my program is is about you know
what's really going on people feel at
the office of their decisions and this
is the only reason why there's a problem
with free will worth talking about that
is are we really the authors of our
decisions dan says no we're not but it
doesn't matter okay I said I said we are
okay well but we're perfectly material
things we're we're moist robots who are
the authors of our decision well in the
same sense that it appears an author of
its well but we have to look closely at
what kind of computer it is okay almost
all right sorry so I think there's
certain number of similarities between
sophisticated theology whooshes this is
deliberately meant to be provocative or
not to have really been something but
there are some similarities between
theologians who don't recognize the
truth of the Bible but nevertheless tell
it to their flock in order to keep them
compliant and compatibilism the first
one is that both define the old notions
in the case of theologians biblical
literalism in the case of comparable is
free will or then claim that nobody
really believes these anymore they're
funny of compatible as you say nobody's
really a dualist okay second of all both
set humans the site is special many
compatible us I'm not sure the ones in
this room say that only humans have free
will and animals don't computers don't
etc so we're it's set aside in that
respect and in both cases academic dough
ends set sometimes say that it's
dangerous for the public to know the
truth neither about you know the fact
that our decisions are determined by our
environments our genes or that you know
maybe God exists as a ground of being
rather than as an actual sky farther out
there okay should we hide it from the
public this is from Dan's Erasmus paper
where he says explicitly that if there
are science are saying that it is no use
we are already puppets controlled by the
environments they're making a big and
potentially harmful mistake but I think
it's true that we are puppets I mean we
are the puppets of our genes and our
environment and they completely
determine what decision will you make so
um there's another quote below that it's
likely to have which Dan just said
profoundly unfortunate social
consequences and another quote which Dan
made on the point of inquiry podcast in
2011 we don't want people disabling
themselves with bad science
I think this is a very serious issue
well I'm not sure that saying that
determinism reigns or the laws of
physics rain is bad science and when I
see a court like this it reminds me of
something that I like said yesterday my
dear are descended from the eighth's
letters let us hope it's not true but if
it is so let us hope not to just not
become generally known ie let's keep the
public unaware of determinism okay you
don't really need to know this is yeah
is it time to I'm almost done okay this
is my next the last slide okay this is a
common error motor of our readers blog
what we're up against human will it's
not free but we must say we must not say
it is so so two more slates actually
welcome why I think that it is important
to concentrate on more than just the
manifest image in the case of free will
first of all and Shawn's gonna object to
this but Dan I think might not because
he says we need to be politically aware
of the uses of our language that if you
say we have free will it somewhat
enables religion we're making a theist
think that the form of free will is
proposed by compatibilist
is the same as their form of fruit which
is truly dualistic that is you can
choose whether or not to accept Jesus it
misses a critical issue the absence of
dualism and the hegemony of the terminal
ism and materialism ie the brains the
way I think this is a very important
message which we need to get out to the
general public and yet people who are
compatible us tend to neglect this and
say well that yeah this is the truth but
you know we have free will in this other
sense and it's to me it's much more
important that the public realize this
then that they have a conception of free
well that comports with determinism for
a number of reasons I think
they they have a conception of free will
in sorry determinism Union I think it
takes may have the danger of taking the
science out of the question of free will
I mean people tend to dismiss the live a
experiments and the sooner all
experiments on grounds other more
substantial as far as I can see them
that they don't like the results all
right well I mean this is meant to be
provocative and gender discovered as I
think it's sidesteps the questions of
morality and moral responsibility are
there if we are truly deterministic in
our decisions is the concept of morality
and moral responsibility have any
meaning at all I mean maybe the concept
of responsibility does but not moral
response rate and I think the most
important reason why we have to keep our
eye on the true reality rather than
manifest image like because I think it
has different consequences for
retribution and punishment I mean
whether or not you punish an
eleven-year-old for beating his little
sister to death depends on what you
think whether you think you know what
motivated that behavior or not and did
that person behave freely anybody I mean
I think that your view that your view of
the river on I'm a philosophical tyro
here okay so I'm not gonna pretend you
know all the nuances but I think
compatible is free well completely
neglects the question unless you start
taking up well will is really determine
bargees environment reflects the very
important question of how we're going to
reform the judicial system of rewards
and punishments based on what we know
about neuroscience okay that and my
modest proposal is that we get rid of
the notion of free well completely and
replace it by this statement which is
for Marvin Minsky my decision was caused
by internal forces I do not understand
and then the really interesting
questions to me which aren't about
questions incompatible
greville ism what are the effects of a
determinism on and view punishment and
reward philosophy and jurisprudence
there's moral responsibility mean
anything beyond responsibility ie you
did it you have to go to jail because
you're the person that did it not
because you were wrong and you argue had
a choice how far ahead coming predict
decisions before they're made
consciously the ambit of responsibility
is science philosophy jurist prints what
are the factors that affect our
decisions and how do they play out in
the brain that's the scientific question
and finally which is a very interesting
one and we have a feeling of agency that
is we can actually make our brains make
a choice which which we can't really is
that feeling ready to see a product of
natural selection why do we feel that
we're agents that have free choices is
that an F of phenomenon or is that a
spandrel or is it something that has
been installed in our brain by natural
selection because as some scientists
think the feeling of agency is an
adaptive one
you